kids book idea mm-hmm okay so it's
called a fishtail and um what's
interesting is I hear I heard Joe Rogan
mention this concept before but I
thought of this all on my own
no way before this was even before the
Jill real good pop yes even existed I
out of this and wrote this book so it's
called a fishtail so it's a story about
a fish and he's in the school and you
know he's just kind of curious kind of
eccentric but you know he's he's a piece
of fish come young and then um one day
he's you know going looking for food or
whatever and he gets this worm floating
around good food right boom get snatched
up boom it's a fisherman caught him swap
it around in the boat right and you know
they take a picture of them and they
throw it back you know catching a
release situation um so he comes back
and and he wasn't gone for what two
minutes maybe mmm so he comes back and
he's like hey guys guess what I just got
yanked you know to the surface over you
know above the surface and a nice like
weird being like a UFO stern right right
so that's the thing so and he was
describing them as like these weird
beings they they didn't need water to
breathe they had you know these weird
appendages kind of like you know they
just weren't anything like us but you
know I saw their eyes but that was kind
of it and then these flashing devices
you know went off and then they just put
me right back and here look at my little
scar I'll even show you and they're like
yeah no no one believed them
they were like II's just an eccentric
fish this you know there's no such thing
as that kind of stuff you know and what
he got a little scar we all have scars
from fucking or whatever but meanwhile
that really happened right so and this
is the parallel there is of course the
UFO the but just cuz it doesn't happen
to everybody doesn't mean that it's not
true necessarily you know so like you
know people claim abductions or whatever
no it does it seems crazy and I straight
up don't believe it
for other reasons other than you know
you don't believe what abductions I
don't think that they're alien
abductions no the the stories of alien
abductions by these people or whatever
that getup did allegedly something like
that happen to me okay it's something we
should talk about on the podcast talk
about it right now what happened is it
I'm just kidding
well here's the thing though but when
you say not you but when someone says I
got abducted by aliens let me tell you
my account um though being abducted by
aliens and then whatever their account
is are two different things no matter
what so they're basically explaining an
experience and then giving a hypothesis
of what it was yeah and most of them not
even the hypotheses they're just saying
straight up that that's what it was
they're putting you know they're they're
naming that experience in basically
verifying it and making it they're
basically saying that that's what it was
their defining it or whatever so and
they're so like any it's like ghosts
when people say they see ghosts you
didn't see good you don't even know what
a ghost is people don't know what a
ghost is it's like you're making the
human race that what's it goes
someone say oh it's someone's spirit
from you know they die and then their
spirit goes and like lives on or
whatever why would you think that
because movies say that because anyone
looking into that can tell you they
there's no evidence of that well and I'm
not saying that's what that's not what
they are I'm not saying that but you are
you're making that claim that that's
what it is and then that's what you saw
so all of all the explanations of your
quote-unquote experience whether you
think you're abducted by aliens all
ghosts whatever saw a Bigfoot your
account of the experience and what
actually happened the explanation of
that experience are two different things
so you can't just put an explanation on
the the experience and all the possible
explanations of your experience there's
literally there's infinite you lost time
you got passed out you woke up in a
field with this
car whatever and you have these weird
memories whatever not memories surname
memories typically just what really
happen the the the real explanation for
your experience there's probably a good
million of them right all the way down
to you imagine the whole thing all the
way down to you're lying all the way
down to you're hallucinating all the way
down to you were hungover so you you
actually got abducted by aliens call
that as one of the million you went
straight to aliens and not only did you
go straight to aliens there's no
evidence for that there's evidence for
people hallucinating there's evidence
for is evidence for all these other
things that you went straight to the one
with no evidence for whatever reason you
know and there's reason for it it so you
can't be mad at the people but that's
why it's hard to believe these things
you know but my little kids book it kind
of puts a little bit of a you know like
not doubt but kind of like but you still
can't dismiss it you know because here's
like an analogy they could uh you know
helped you believe let's do this free
fighting back at yarn about like two
minute I was yeah I hell did I don't
want that to be on video